rated M for Mature  I thought you were gonna be by my side  at Craster's but you broke your vows  there's no coming back from this my  family is counting on me to put things  right those aren't going to stop me why  did you come here  I just need your help myself swords will  help me free the slaves of Marie get  them into the city and I will see that  you are rewarded why the hell are you  drinking I have always hated this place  Lord Whitehill is conspiring against my  family and someone is helping him loner  something's happened  I command father's Elite Guard they're  yours if you'll help us take down Griff  it's time someone brought Grif now  what are your orders  you